[Musica]
certo che parlare di robot dopo pratichi
si è come andare al camp nou in genere
pallone dopo mesi sarà impossibile ci
proviamo ma sarà dura dura dura sfoggia
la buona sera siamo sono felice di
essere qui
alzo guten tag multe nabel un ace e
patrizia henninger buonasera e nei
numeri e patrizia fenninger on it clean
cleo click o in vita sono felice di
essere qui a foggia per il the backs a
pervenire mi disse tu me cloud
sono felice di essere qui con pasquale
il clown imbecille
vision cloud sei un clown sei un cretino
perché in questo modo alimenti il
pregiudizio che una con un cognome
tedesco non possa parlare italiano e
soprattutto senza accento ed è un po
come dire che il robot saranno coloro
che ci porteranno alla fine come genere
umano
il che è un po un approccio anti
scientifico e onestamente sottolinea la
paura verso un futuro e della paura che
purtroppo ahimè ritroviamo anche in
contesti più creativi di intellettuali
quante volte infatti troviamo ancora
oggi l'edificio anche dei ted che hanno
dei titoli così e penso sia anche per
questo che sono cinque anni ormai che
pasquale sta lavorando su un rapporto
tra creatività e intelligenza
artificiale e l'anno scorso per esempio
fatto questo mancato questo insieme a
pasquale ea sergio spaccavento si chiama
clan verso sanctis che un format
teatrale per spiegare che è proprio
questo il punto non c'è nessuna lotta
tra un creativo è un ingegnere anzi se
solo una splendida opportunità una una
bellissima occasione di far partire
delle scintille in ambito creativo verso
quelli che sono i robot per la
comunicazione tori di interrompersi
pensare di fare la guerra e robot è come
andare contro grano armato con una
fionda e assolutamente ingenuo mentre
invece c'è una cosa straordinaria noi
stiamo parlando soprattutto di robot
conversazionali stiamo parlando di robot
che permettono di esprimere la
creatività
questi sono degli straordinari colleghi
di lavoro sono macchine che ti
permettono di trattare enormi quantità
di dati che il mio cervello non potrebbe
comunque e di farlo anche in tempi super
rapidi veramente alla velocità della
luce
quindi il vero problema è che bisogna
per essere all'altezza di questi gruppo
di queste macchine bisogna lavorare
studiare tantissimo da fare è essere e
diventare degli uomini e delle donne
migliori e questo ragazzi questo può far
paura soprattutto ai più giovani
questo si deve far paura invece da
questo punto di vista
le persone sagge hanno un atteggiamento
molto più sano per esempio questi giorni
heggarty uno dei più grandi direttori
creativi e creativi della pubblicità del
mondo ecco alla sinistra
dal punto di vista tecnico lui presente
non ha paura lui dice l'intelligenza
artificiale ci aiuta a diventare dei
migliori creativi perché noi con la
nostra sensibilità
solo noi possiamo prendere daytime turn
into magic prendere i dati e trasformali
in magia in narrazione in scrittura voi
potete anche provare a far scrivere le
macchine però diciamoci la verità ci
sono degli esperimenti nelle mostre 1
meraviglioso in cui si è presa una frase
evangelica in inglese e si è detto al
robot trovavo in maniera più originale
più creativa di raccontare questa frase
il robot come un bambino di sei anni ha
preso il dizionario delle di sinonimi e
ha pubblicato questa frase che come dire
patrizia cosa è successo esattamente una
kermesse che è forte ma la carne e
marcia e non è esattamente quello che
allora che capite che questa roba è
imbarazzante
cioè non abbiamo bisogno noi creativi
siamo sufficientemente folli matti
illogici non abbiamo bisogno che sia un
computer a fare queste follie come dice
ma ciò capatonda l'umanità verrà salvata
dell'intelligenza artificiale della
stupidità umana
da questo punto di vista quindi bisogna
lavorare sul fatto che il robot possono
migliorare i creativi per esempio questo
è un esperimento fatto a
tokyo in giappone dove una grande
agenzia di pubblicità ha preso un robot
l'ha caricato con tutti i filmati
pubblicitari degli ultimi 50 anni l'ha
nominato con questo dato in base a
questo database direttore creativo e ha
aperto una gara interna in cui il
direttore creativo robot con dei giovani
creativi alle prime armi è stato sfidato
a lavorare su delle caramelline alla
menta contro un direttore creativo di
grande esperienza un direttore anziano
pasquale sono abbastanza anziano ma non
così anziano morale che cosa è successo
sono stati prodotti due spot
adesso vi faccio vedere lo chiamano alla
regia il primo spot ci spostiamo lo
facciamo vedere fatto dal robot
direttore creativo prego forse parte il
numero due
[Musica]
come dire mi permetto di dire che non è
che c'è qualcosa anche in italia abbiamo
fatto dei film così dove c'è il cane che
vola il jingle la musichetta quindi
niente di particolarmente originale
davanti però sapendo il direttore
creativo anziano esperto sapendo che il
robot avrebbe fatto quello cioè
rielaborare cose esistenti che cosa ha
fatto si è inventato qualcosa di molto
personale molto originale film 13 grazie
[Musica]
so kocsis chi si opponeva carezze di una
cultura giapponese è molto vicino a noi
però vi faccio una domanda non mi sembra
che il direttore tipo umano abbia fatto
un lavoro molto più originale rispetto a
quello che ha fatto il computer
il robot ecco questa è la vera forza c'è
la possibilità che i computer ci
spingano a migliorarci come creativi e a
fare qualcosa che non avremmo mai
pensato di fare a ideare qualcosa di
nuovo
e poi non c'è solo questo perché il
robot possono diventare quindi le
macchine diventano sono diventare dei
personaggi degli attori gente che ci
come dire che interpreta una parte
patriziale volentieri parliamone
parliamo di charbon e possiamo dire a
cosa anche molto interessante ce ne sono
anche di divertenti il team creativo di
spaccamento ha lanciato sui social
quest'anno un robot tecnicamente ma che
è capace di rispondere tramite messenger
per un superalcolico irlandese e la cosa
divertente è già il fatto che si chiami
ciao io sono bot
james spot che è già una cosa molto
ironica è già una caratterizzazione
quasi umanoide se pensiamo che tutto che
per il giorno di san patrick's che al di
là di essere il giorno proprio il
patrono dell'irlanda e anche il patrono
delle sbronze tecnicamente cosa succede
che l'utente chattando con questo botta
man mano che la conversazione andava
avanti aveva veramente a che fare con un
bot
ubriaco a lia di avere un linguaggio
grottesco è abbastanza
come dire forte è stato fatto un lavoro
veramente utile perché c'è stata
sensibilizzazione e migliaia di persone
di utenti hanno potuto capire e provare
in un certo modo quasi di persona
l'esperienza di una sbronza
un altro esempio molto interessante
completamente un altro linguaggio
e questo dove tecnicamente il robot che
comunica in modo eccezionale tramite
messenger è un manga disegnato da un
talento e da un team italiano di
publisys
a milano lui sa vendervi con grandissima
destrezza delle macchine di qualsiasi
sorta vorrei dire quindi l'invito è se
volete conoscere e capire come può
essere anche affascinante un robot di
andare a trovarlo e curiosare su questo
che può essere la sull'indirizzo dimesso
inesatto ci sono inoltre dei bot
diciamo che sono già integrati nel
prodotto in caso lampante è quello di
ello barbie è un caso americano
inventata ideato da luca times che
parlamento e conoscete di più per il
lavoro che ha fatto prima in quanto
lavorava alla pixar centro la famosa
casa di produzione di cartoni animati
per bambini e non solo per me ma
assolutamente che cosa succede a lavarvi
praticamente funziona in presenza di un
wifi si connette la bambola con il cavo
lo smartphone è lei comincia veramente a
parlare senza terminare senza finire mai
a chiacchierare coi bambini in
praticamente come aver a che fare con un
toy story del quotidiano
ma la cosa abbastanza particolare è che
questo ceppo questo questo robot biondo
passerà probabilmente molto più tempo
con i bimbi di quanto non possono fare i
genitori quando non possiamo fare noi
questo chiaramente apre delle dinamiche
e delle discussioni molto più ampie
molto più delicate come l'etica il pari
bridge le aree esattamente e anche
quello che è il nostro la nostra
responsabilità nei confronti queste
tematiche ma non l'affrontiamo oggi oggi
non affrontiamo oggi ci concentriamo
quindi dopo aver visto un robot che
scrivono a robot che parlano robot che
diventano personaggi prodotti che
diventano robot bambole che diventano
robot parliamo anche nel fatto che
spesso l'intelligenza artificiale nei
chip viene usata attraverso i messenger
attraverso i telefonini addirittura
all'interno dei telefonini ci sono gli
smartphone ci sono delle intelligenze
artificiali che possono diventare
strumenti espressivi per i creativi ma
soprattutto per i manager
qui vi raccontiamo un caso di un
recentissimo della scorsa settimana di
una manager italiana giovanissima
nella stessa età di patrizia si chiama
isabella lazzini che ha finanziato i vvf
è una ricerca in mare aperto fuori dalle
azzorre cercando di prendere il canto
delle megattere e trasformarlo in come
dire attraverso l'intelligenza
artificiale del suo prodotto in qualcosa
di nuovo
vediamo questo pezzettino e riuscire ad
affrontare i versi negozio linguaggio
d'amore in una forma che sia
universalmente fruibile al grande
pubblico lo trovo una cosa straordinaria
lo studio del calcio e la megattera si
inserisce nell'ambito della ustica
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il processore di nuovo imac 20 pro ha
imparato a riconoscere le frequenze dei
vocalizzi presenti nel canto delle
megattere e a collegarle a una
progressione armonica che proprio una
sequenza di note
una volta identificato l'insieme di
notte il modello sfrutta la doppia rete
neurale per improvvisare una melodia
trasformando così il canto e la
megattera è una canzone
[Musica]
l'intelligenza artificiale struttura
come se fosse quasi il compositore una
melodia
il potenziale straordinario dell'uso
creativo dell'intelligenza artificiale
per fare delle cose allora da questo
punto di vista e torniamo sulla nostra
slide capite che non sono opportunità da
cogliere cioè io stesso se quando ero
ragazzino non avessi colto le radio
private le prime agenzie di pubblicità
oppure un po più grande al primo
internet avrei perso le occasioni
professionali per cui alla fine mi hanno
chiamato qui a parlare su questo palco
allo stesso modo oggi perdere la
capacità di per esempio usare la voce
all'interno di questi strumenti e
sarebbe veramente una grande perdita
sarebbe attaccato e assolutamente siamo
nel pieno di una rivoluzione
basti pensare che nel 2020 la metà delle
ricerche che non fatte sul web passerà
attraverso questi aiutanti vocali e così
a padova insieme agli amici di side by
side con pasquale stanno toccando con
mano che sta questa rivoluzione tramite
quello che è un boys assistenti italiano
e che praticamente fa uso del ispica
boldi google e l'altra parte dell'estro
e la creatività del suo ideatore in
questo caso si chiama alessio pomaro
ecco qua vediamo il concept del logo per
spiegare come è fatto praticamente sono
due basi si occupa dalla parte di
machine learning e di collaboration che
la macchina questo equilibrio saluto con
una fortissima struttura l'impianto il
cuore praticamente viene dato dall idea
da umano arrivarvi validatore il
creatore esattamente
e questo dà vita a lisa questo il nome
significa lisa is simple up e ed è un
prototipo ancora ma sarà utilissimo in
tutti quelli che saranno i contesti di
voice
voice commerce stanziate generale è un
assistente che vi permetterà di fare
delle cose abbiamo simulato un futuro
neanche lontanissimo che 20 20 e qua
dietro in cui uno di noi
decido io poi sono un po di pancetta
devo rimettermi a corre e decide che sta
guidando a decide di rimettersi a
correre deve comprare delle scarpe è una
cosa fa abbiamo simulato la
conversazione con cui un umano si
interfaccia lisa la sua assistente
comprò paio di scarpe partiamo con il
video per favore e google mi fai parlare
con l'esa ok buona continuazione
ciao alessio cosa posso fare per te ciao
lisa dovrei cambiare scarpa da running
cosa mi consigli questa settimana ci
sono le a steve jennings 20 a 122 euro
cosa ne pensi per farlo bruciarli pure e
paga che il numero metto nel carrello il
45 grazie qualche preferenza per il
colore sono disponibile in azzurro
silver va benissimo l'azzurro bene il
procedo con l'acquisto
grazie alessio riceverai una mail di
notifica dell'ordine saranno in consegna
lunedì ei google chiama pietro e digli
che martedì andiamo a correre
metti tutto il calendario grazie ok
alessio procedo questo potenziale per i
creativi nel poter creare dare vita e
carattere a un prodotto di questo tipo
chiaramente serve il talento e non solo
il talento ovviamente però dell'essere
umano
poi è chiaro e robot potranno
migliorarsi con il tempo assolutamente
ma saremo sempre noi a dar vita
inizialmente è sempre noi creativi
potremo poi intervenire anche narrazione
attenzione però stiamo parlando sempre
di talento umano che viene aggiunto alla
capacità di calcolo della macchina è
sempre l'umano che dà la personalità la
linguistica addirittura vi dico senza
grandi problemi che non parliamo solo di
talento ma parliamo di coraggio di
bellezza di capacità di usare rischiare
nessun robot per esempio da solo sarebbe
capace di prendere un pazzo come klaus
davi
e seguirlo nell'avventura di fare delle
campagne contro i boss di mafia e
ndrangheta
nessun robot sarebbe capace di pensare a
delle campagne in cui si mostrano questi
boss latitanti travestiti da femminelli
che è l'unica maniera che hanno per
uscire di casa e non farsi beccare dalla
polizia
nessun robot sarebbe in grado di andare
di notte ad appendere questi manifesti a
palermo ea reggio calabria nei quartieri
più rischiosi stiamo parlando di mattia
missione denaro sia parlando di rocco
morabito stiam parlando di nicola assisi
capite che il robot può programmare ma
non può fare queste cose il labor non
potrà mai vincere il premio borsellino
per aver prodotto delle cose così belle
belle e coraggiose a proposito di
bellezza e coraggio siamo in fondo
dobbiamo arrivare per non sforare
questa è una grande un grande
personaggio è una scienziata ma è anche
un'attrice hedy lamarr che ci dimostra
come dobbiamo essere perché poi il
problema è per essere più bravi dei
robot dobbiamo essere così dobbiamo
essere profondi umani molti filosofi ma
anche rigorosi scienziati ma anche
pragmatici portare queste cose a terra
perché solo così solo se saremo molto
più bravi dei robot saremmo i
sostituibili
e chiaro che bisogna studiare studiare
studiare e chiaro che bisognerà cercare
di migliorarsi
bisognerà migliorarsi non c'è solo
cercare e bisognerà produrre idee
bisognerà essere più bravi dei robot e
soprattutto realizzarle perché le idee
se ti restano in testa non servono più a
niente non regalate le idee
assolutamente questa è una scultura che
ho creato con 100 banconote da 100 euro
per ricordare questo concetto non
regalare le idee significa mantenere il
valore che l'elemento fondamentale che
ci distingue dai robot vi saluto anche
io con il mio madre la mia frase che mi
ha permesso di aprire la mia agenzia 22
anni dopo gli studi e che
quotidianamente mi porta a generare
scintille e continuamente mi porta a
giocare anche con i paradossi maestro
che abbiamo l'onore di chiudere il trust
veramente buona partita e vogliamo
provare a svelare il segreto della
scintilla
a generare la scintilla è molto semplice
mi credi avvicinarmi ma basta rimanere
umani e non sono bastate bene domani ma
altre oltretutto basta essere in pole
imperfetta parola magica imperfetti
perché se si ammette di essere
imperfetti
si cerca di migliorarsi abbiamo logica
di portare a casa un grande risultato
abbiamo un obbligo esatta è quello di
essere insostituibili
cerchiamo di esserlo vi ringraziamo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]